injured players patrick beverley out
missing his fourth straight game and on
the turnover backed up the suffix Briana
112 turnovers for the Celtics only four
points for the Clippers lose hesitates
puts up a contested ten footer and
knocks it in 25 for Lou go to work on
Lulu smart is a good post up player he
passes out there very well - there's
Tatum Clippers in possession down by
three Williams yes Lou Williams has been
unstoppable 30 points to suite room
that's at 15 of this 30 here of a
fourth-quarter bit of 35 to go Tatum on
a fake what a night for the first time
all-star as we approach 3 minutes to go
in OT Williams own shot by Lou Williams
32 points for Lou and his fifth
three-pointer
there's Williams yes no Williams
continues his red-hot shooting Tatum
taunted by Shannon Tatum
[Applause]
half minute remaining 15 on the shot
clock
Tatum with the step and still puts to a
palm right there is Tatum on the drive
and why I like this move right here
gunshot Madan him and he's pulled up and
for a jumper earlier fake the jumper got
in there
Harrell came over to contest and he just
powered it up there